leo I've mountain here Uncle Peter said
come on Madeline stop being such a
chicken
check this out what is it I have no idea
are you hey snapshots back 20 jointly it
is no fun being frozen and on cold
bloody man it's been a wild crocodile
good to see another one of the trap
masters back at Skyland yeah were you
guys dead when chaos blew up cloud
crack-up reason the trap masters were
blown into another dimension luckily
some portal masters found me and boom
made back this is Leo and Men ah do they
speak yeah it's a lot to take in kids
with the skylanders and this is skyler
easy we do have a small villain problem
hold on are you saying we haven't caught
all the villains yet it's tough to trap
him without trapped aenean crystals the
prison was made of the stuff but now
it's all gone wait if we were blown into
their world maybe the crystals were too
leo Madeleine we need your help look
around for colorful crystals we can use
them to trap the villains inside and
make them fight for us
I think about something like this yeah
yeah you found one it's Wolfgang you not
good well well look who we have here the
trap news is we're the trap master's
mate and we're about to teaching old
dogs new tricks
Leo the trap put it in the portal wait
what's happening I get in here I'll be
back in oh good I swear it's okay Leo
he's one of us now feels good to be good
now that's a good dog
run away run away we couldn't have done
it without you guys
we only had more trips
nice could you trap with this
now when you beat a bad guy you can
capture them in a crystal trap then send
them back to fight for you
over 60 new skylanders 40 travel
villains and one amazing new adventure
capture evil unleash good Skylanders
trap team some toys and consult sold
separately